[Music]
hey guys welcome to another installment
of Harry Potter theory in this video
we'll be discussing Dumbledore Tom
Riddle and how Dumbledore first became
familiar with the powerful young boy in
the orphanage in one scene in the
half-blood Prince Harry visits
Dumbledore in his quarters Dumbledore
then directs Harry towards his pensive a
magical object which is used to review
memories Harry begins to use the pensive
and explores Dumbledore's memories he's
then suddenly taken back to the year
1938 when a young ish Dumbledore is
shown visiting a very troubled looking
boy sitting alone in the room of an
orphanage during Dumbledore's visit to
the orphanage he reveals to the boy that
he is a wizard and subsequently shows
him an impressive display of magical
ability riddle is in all and shortly
after this moment
Dumbledore invites him to Hogwarts Tom
Riddle was of course a terrifying
hostile child who tormented the other
orphans but this was not something that
Dumbledore knew about until later on it
also didn't matter he wouldn't be denied
entry to Hogwarts because of this
everyone deserves a chance after riddle
began attending the school Dumbledore
researched riddle and became more
familiar with his existence however he
was still mostly unaware of his dark
nature this begs the question how did
Dumbledore find riddle in the first
place he was just an orphan to begin to
answer this question we need to look at
the quill of acceptance and a book of
admittance Pottermore states to
following in a small locked tower never
visited by any student and Hogwarts sits
an ancient book that is not been touched
by human hands since the four founders
placed it there on completion of the
castle beside the book which is bound in
peeling black dragon hide stands a small
silver ink pot and from this protrudes a
long faded quill these are the quill of
acceptance and the book of admittance
and they constitute the only process by
which students are selected for Hogwarts
School of Witchcraft and Wizardry the
book and quill were put in place by the
founders of Hogwarts to aid with and
automate the Hogwarts election process
one of the main parameters put in place
for detecting students is as follows at
the precise moment that a child first
exhibits signs of magic the quill which
is believed to have been taken from an
augury floats up out of his ink pot and
attempts to inscribe the name of that
child upon the pages of the book this
means that as soon as the child shows
any form of magic it is immediately set
in writing they are a magical being no
child would be able to perform magic
undetected without this magical book and
quill taking note of it what this means
is that while riddle was in the
orphanage he must have performed magic
effectively putting him on their radar
one common misconception about children
showing initial signs of magic is that
the ministry is alerted once the child
has the tray supplied to them the
ministry will know about any sort of
magical activity that they engage in
but before they're registered the
Hogwarts headmaster is the first to know
as he's the one with the immediate
access to the quill of acceptance and
book of admittance the headmaster of
Hogwarts at the time was not Dumbledore
but
Armondo Dippet who presided as
headmaster until sometime between 1965
and 1971 Dumbledore was deputy
headmaster and the Transfiguration
professor at Hogwarts during this time
because of Dumbledore's role he carried
out responsibilities similar to
McGonagall and would aid in informing
children's parents of their child's
admittance to Hogwarts Dumbledore
learned of riddles existence sometime
between his initial inscription inside
the book of admittance and the day that
he turned 11 years old while it's
suggested that Dumbledore knew nothing
of riddle originally I sincerely doubt
that Dumbledore is an incredibly
intelligent and studious individual and
I have no doubt that he did at least
some form of intensive research on
riddle before his initial visit he may
not have known about the extent of his
dark nature or the truly destructive
power that he possessed but I'm sure
that he knew at least a little bit about
his background and heritage after Harry
is finished with the pensive he has the
following exchange with Dumbledore did
you know sir then did I know that I had
just met the most dangerous Dark Wizard
of all time No
and that's it for this video if you
enjoyed it please give the video a like
until next time
you're a wizard Harry
[Music]